it
so when you're doing human shamanucci
there's like lots of things
so since he made it he's in he had the
book buddho
he said
he's not like he stood like this
and he's thinking oh he's going to say
something of really words of wisdom and
he said check the ground around you this
is not said nothing about the technique
so over the years i i've worked out what
we do
so
i'm in hand me my partner's inheritance
you have to be careful if you come in
too strong like this
the hand goes out here and it's way
above his head look
and this is supposed to actually been
a temmie into his face
so we want to not just throw it out or
else that's what happens
we watch us as if it's riding up our
chest
and then as we move forward it comes out
at the last minute it doesn't come out
first
it comes up and it's like a wave
okay
if he stands back up
that's how high it should be
since he often said to people why are
you
why are you up there you know there's
nobody that tall if they are better to
run
so this is a
bring the thumb up look at your
breastbone
and come up
grip here he always said grip here now
in aikikai they do this
and the reason
this is okay if you're training in the
dojo because training the dojo hands
open your partner
normally will follow you
out there in the street some guy who's
got bent nose and you know he's been in
prison more times for gbh it's not going
to flow with you so what you do is
this connection means that you're
connected
so hopefully you know if he moves about
you've got a connection so sensei would
say
make sure you always have one hand
attached
to them make sure you have one hand
when you enter attached to them
[Music]
up your breastbone
enter
please watch the feet
i'm going to do it incorrect first
because i'm going to just go in so i'm
going to come in at the west bone come
in
at this point
we turn them out and the foot comes out
and we
hit their bodies
down
this is a standard
robotic way of doing it
but i've learned over the years
that uh 99 of aikido is a temmy
so where's the atemi going to be in this
so this is the part i want to give away
it's like a splash
notice my hands coming together apart
in the second kamitachi when we hit our
kens together
i use the bounce to go up to their wrist
so when i come in here
i do that it's almost like we just give
a little kiss like this
and we take it away and that's not tell
me
because
what
we don't realize is a chiropractor
has a little electron not electron it
has a little machine i don't know if
you've ever seen it they hold it with
two fingers it's spring loaded they set
the tension and they go ping down your
back or on muscles
so i asked the uh
chiropractor
do your hands hurt you know i use well
i've done so many bodies
is it um that you find now that you
can't manipulate because years ago they
would manipulate the body
and they said what they found out was
the body's
muscles react faster than the
chiropractor can adjust the muscles
so just as about they go to adjust the
muscle
the person would spasm and they couldn't
get it unless they really sort of done
some very vigorous
so i realized that in iccio what i sense
he gave us as the first technique and
it's really quite a horrible technique
to get any feedback
but if you do this
he sees
his muscle won't stiffen up
because
he hasn't felt
that
so i took this from the chiropractor so
this is how aikido in daily life can
teach us about the body
if i go here
without
him knowing he will
automatically have tighter muscles he
will be harder to so your most of you
know how hard it is to get somebody down
in ikea if they don't want to go
so their mind is sort of saying go on
then you know put it on
so this splash so we've got two things
in this
program this
splash means that yes i've got him here
what he was what his mind won't know
about
because this is what his eyes saw and
thought was gonna do the work
so
so now when i do that
he doesn't realize how easy he goes down
without a lot of fuss
so
i come in
that's very very difficult to do
i now
rewind that
with this motion
and
it brings up
the rest of the technique
that's how you've got
up the breastbone
splash
flap down
and then that part
so now
taking it a bit more
it's really difficult because you've
added all these things and you've got to
add a tem is in
what will attempt to his mind but oh
there wasn't a reaction so that means it
was a good attempt
see
if you get his attention but you don't
actually hurt
him the next thing is i'd like you to
look at the feet
so when i come in
even with this splash if i come in
direct like that
it's difficult now to get him down here
because now he's costing my path and
i've gotta get him
over there
but he's in my path so i have to push
him off
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
change my football
i'm going to come up with my breastplate
and then
it's difficult because i'm coming
directly out
but then i'm gonna
just scoot off so that if he was to cut
me with a sword or anything
i'd be that's why you've been doing
weapons all this time
it's taught you how to get offline
so
now
i can just walk through easily that path
without
being disturbed
so
you know it's taken all these years for
me well i understood a long while ago it
took me so many years to realize why
would no sense you give us a difficult
technique
but to him
when you see the technique performed
as one
you don't realize what's going on
once you've understood
this
you can understand
just watch
watch the splash
watch stuff
i make sure that he doesn't allow
pressure
on
i don't let him have the
pleasure
of being
my pal against his power
i take it off
all the time
and i shape
i shake that
don't okay